[Música]
el 2 de abril de 1982 comenzó la guerra
de las malvinas como 6 la llama en
argentina o fue clarence según los
británicos tras una ofensiva lanzada por
el gobierno militar argentino ese país
se reclama como propias las islas
ocupadas o por reino unido desde 1833 la
guerra del juego 650 combatientes
argentinos y 255 británicos muertos
nuestro corresponsal en buenos aires-
natalio cos hoy converso con guillermo
carmona el secretario de malvinas
también antártida y atlántico sur veamos
la entrevista nos acompañan en france 24
guillermo carmona es secretario de
malvinas antártida de atlántico sur de
argentina para conversar porque se
cumplen este año a los 40 años de la
guerra de malvinas en la que se enfrentó
a argentina con reino unido por la
soberanía de esas islas que ayer
reunidos llaman falklands aquí se llaman
malvinas muchas gracias por recibirse a
ustedes un gusto que cambie este año que
tiene de especial que sean los 40 años
aunque va a ocurrir en el contexto de
este aniversario tan peculiar
bueno en primer lugar es un
doble aniversario de 40 años por un lado
ya hacen 40 años que el reino unido
congelo unilateralmente las
negociaciones con la república argentina
sufrió a fines del año
argentina entre el año
1965 y
1981 estuvo en varias circunstancias
diálogos y negociaciones con el reino
unido por el tema de la soberanía esa
situación
lamentablemente se vio cortada por una
decisión unilateral del reino unido-
en diciembre del año 81 y luego en abril
se produce
la decisión de la dictadura
cívico-militar
y recuperación de las islas y esto
desencadena lo que conocemos como el
conflicto del atlántico sur en ese
contexto para nosotros estos 40 años son
una ocasión en primer lugar para
reconocer y homenajear a los caídos en
la guerra de malvinas a los
excombatientes
ellos no decidieron
ir a la guerra fue una decisión adoptada
por
el gobierno de la dictadura
cívico-militar y
consideramos que más allá de lo
cuestionable de la decisión adoptada por
la dictadura
es importante reconocer aquellos que
cumplieron con su deber ante la patria
por lo tanto
el 2 de abril que es el día en que por
ley
conmemoramos el día del veterano guerra
y de los caídos en la guerra de malvinas
vamos a homenajear los muy especialmente
pero también es una oportunidad para que
durante todo este año
visibilizamos la cuestión malvinas en la
argentina y en el mundo en este sentido
cómo está la posibilidad de recuperar un
diálogo que permita avanzar en algún
tipo de reclamo está presente es
persistente en todos los foros
internacionales argentina mantiene el
reclamo pero ese diálogo con el gobierno
británico de estado británico no termina
de avanzar y uno ve que desde
desde la guerra hoy no parece haber
cambiado mucho la situación segunda voz
y cambio nal hay una hay una serie de
cambios pero ahí hay reticencia
británica a cumplir el derecho
internacional porque desde el año 1965
son una gran cantidad
las resoluciones que han determinado que
las partes tienen que sentarse a
dialogar y a negociar lo plantea la
asamblea general de naciones unidas el
comité de descolonización el reino unido
tiene la obligación de negociar porque
naciones unidas reconocen que hay una
disputa de soberanía y que se trata de
un caso de un caso pendiente de
colonialismo que tiene que ser resuelto
para el reino unido
la negativa a renunciar tiene un costo
de reputación el reino unido está
incumpliendo sistemáticamente
el derecho internacional y la mayoría de
los países del mundo reconocen esta
situación y lo hacen manifiesto en
naciones unidas en la oea en distintos
foros internacionales y regionales
al mismo tiempo el reino unido estaba
incumpliendo
normativa internacional y por ejemplo le
obliga a dar cuenta de la introducción
de armamento nuclear durante la guerra
de malvinas en estos días el canciller
cafiero
exigido explicaciones al reino unido-
por las últimas revelaciones que han
habido de la introducción de 31 armas
nucleares durante la guerra de malvinas
en el atlántico sur violando la
normativa internacional de no
proliferación de armas nucleares
e incluso el tratado de
tlatelolco que es el que dispone que
américa latina y caribe son zonas libres
de armas nucleares también
realiza actos unilaterales del reino
unido en contra del derecho
internacional militar militarizando las
islas
autorizando pesca ilegal y
avanzando en la actividad de exploración
hidrocarburífera
todo esto tiene un costo de reputación
por el reino unido- la argentina está
lista para sentarse en la mesa de
negociaciones
esperamos que el reino unido
decida terminar con esta historia de
incumplimientos del derecho
internacional el actual contexto
internacional puede ser favorable para
argentina en ese sentido
aquí está el centro de atención o el eje
sobre esta disputa que tiene argentina
con reino unido vivimos un momento muy
crítico en el mundo
[Música]
sin lugar a dudas es muy difícil hacer
previsiones de cómo puede ser el
desenlace de esta situación
conflictiva que se desarrolla en europa
de todos modos hay un elemento que sí es
muy importante de esta cara
la absoluta mayoría de los países del
mundo han reconocido la vigencia del
principio de integridad territorial que
es el principio que se aplica para
malvinas el reino unido ha estado
reclamando le al mundo que en ucrania se
respete la integridad territorial
es el mismo reino unido- que viola la
integridad territorial de la argentina
desde hace 189 años a partir de la
usurpación de esta parte del territorio
argentino sin lugar a dudas está
reafirmación de la vigencia del
principio de integridad territorial es
muy importante argentina bueno
además
podría tal vez algunos se preguntan a
aprovechar
o haber aprovechado la salida de reino
unido de la unión europea a través del
break city para empezar a buscar una
alternativa
a través de la unión europea también
presionará reino unido
sobre el reclamo argentino en malvinas
no sé si es algo que se ha explorado
desde el país o no la posibilidad de que
la unión europea acompaña el reclamo
argentino mucho se ha hablado respecto
de que el break sheet es una oportunidad
y sin lugar a dudas lo lo es se produjo
un resultado muy favorable para la
argentina que fue que
malvinas quedó excluida del acuerdo de
salida del reino unido de la unión
europea eso es un aspecto importante eso
no tuvo que ver con una acción del
gobierno anterior pero se produjo y ese
es un hecho muy positivo y actualmente
estamos desarrollando una acción muy
intensa
ante las instituciones europeas y
también hacia los países europeos para
conseguir
el reconocimiento de que hay una disputa
de soberanía y de incumplimiento del
derecho internacional por parte del
reino mía habíamos dicho que sobre todo
iba a estar focalizado en los
excombatientes y en los familiares de
los caídos de este 40 aniversario que
les termina o que todavía le debe el
estado argentino a esos ex combatientes
ya sus familiares la argentina tuvo
periodos de desmalvinización períodos en
los cuales
sí
intento invisibilizar la cuestión
malvinas como causa nacional y esto
llevó a que sobre todo en la última
parte de la dictadura militar y en
algunos momentos de la democracia
argentina
los veteranos de guerra y los familiares
de dos caídas tuvieran dificultades para
ser reconocidos por el estado desde el
año 2004
a partir de la presidencia de néstor
kirchner se instaura la pensión
honorífica en los veteranos de guerra ya
como un reconocimiento específico
se ha avanzado en un régimen
de pensión también para las
incapacidades discapacidades perdón
sobrevivientes como consecuencia de la
participación en la guerra
se les ha otorgado el derecho a una
jubilación anticipada
hay una serie de medidas que se han ido
adoptando sin lugar a dudas la atención
del estado tiene que ser permanente
quedan nuevos desafíos sobre todo para
trabajar en garantizar
y atención médica y la atención
psicológica en favor de la salud física
y psicológica de los veteranos y de los
otros familiares en donde
permanentemente hay que hay que seguir
atendiendo a que el servicio sea el
adecuado hoy se prestan esos servicios
pero hay seguramente aspectos que se
pueden mejorar y estamos trabajando en
el gobierno
pero carmona muchas gracias por
acompañarnos